my name is mathias and in this
video we look at the culprit for
dependent random samples and at the end of this video
i will show you how you
can easily calculate the culprit online on date
up de and that brings
us to the first question, what is it
actually the culprit is for dependent samples the culprit is for dependent
samples checked whether the
mean values ​​of two dependent samples
differ significantly from each other
what exactly is a
dependent sample in the case of dependent
samples where the measured values ​​come in pairs before the
pairs result, for example, from
mass repetition at  the same people
so that it is easier to understand here is
a small example
let's say you want to find out whether
holidays have an influence on people's
stress levels to
find out you created a small
online questionnaire on
the stairs with which you measure people's stress levels
with the  questionnaire ask
d  u now people before and after their
vacation about their stress level here there
are two options
option one you interview people
before they fly on vacation and
then interview other people after they
come back from their vacation in this case
you would have an independent stand by test
because they  people you asked before the holiday
have
nothing to do with the people you asked about the holiday
the second option and
in this case a better option would be to ask the people you
interviewed before they go on
holiday and then ask the
same people after their holiday  In
this case, you would have a dependent
sample, so the readings are
always in pairs, so if the people have
nothing to do with each other,
you have an independent sample. If
the people you ask before and after are
the same, so the
readings are in pairs, you have
a dependent random sample for exactly
this case then becomes the perpetrator  s
dependent samples used before you
can calculate the offender you must of
course first
formulate the hypotheses in the case of dependent
offenders the null hypothesis is there is
no significant difference
between the means of the two
dependent groups and the alternative
hypothesis is there is a
significant difference between the
means of the two dependent
groups therefore one hypothesis is there
is no difference and the other is
about the thesis there is a difference of
course you can also formulate directed
or one-sided hypotheses
then the new hypothesis would be
a group has a significantly
smaller or the same mean and
the alternative  Hypothesis A group has
a significantly larger mean value
Of course you can
also turn it around to smaller and larger depending on how
the question is how it works
now but the dependent is certain
we'll look at that again of course
an example for repeating the
offenders is checked for dependent samples
whether the mean value of 2
dependent samples
differs significantly from each other let's say you
want to check whether a
highly developed diet program has a
possible influence on the weight of
people for this you are looking for
subjects who  are
ready to complete the
diet program of the subjects measure the weight once before
and once after the de program, thereby
the weight of the subjects once before and
once after the diet program is
the measured values ​​are in pairs and you have
a dependent random sample as a zero
hypothesis  is that the diet program has
no significant impact on the
body weight of the participants and your
alternative hypothesis is the
diet program has an impact on the
body weight of the participants of course
you could also make a directed
hypothesis because an alternative
hypothesis would then be either the
diet program  reduces the body weight
significantly or the diet program significantly decreases
the body weight but
enough about the hypotheses how do you calculate
the culprit is for dependent
random samples each test person you lie
once before and once after the
completed program we
are not interested in the weight before and
after, but we are  is
actually only interested in the difference between before
and after i.e. how much a person
has gained or lost so we calculate
the difference between before and after
of each person who
through this we have converted the two godfather values ​​into a new value through this conversion
we have from  made the two datasets
one by the fact that we now only have
one dataset is the perpetrator
for dependent samples is now
equivalent to the test for one sample
let's say the first person has gained six
kilograms the second person
has lost four kilograms the third
has seven kilograms  removed  en and the
fourth gained five kilograms
on average the participants lost
0.75 kilograms now the
big question is whether de is
responsible for this
difference or whether this
difference is purely
coincidental and the diet actually has no
influence  to answer this question
you now need the culprit
for dependent random samples now
some of you will surely call stop what
about the requirements
they have to be checked first that is
absolutely right but
first I would like to explain the basics with a simple example
and then  go
into the requirements to calculate the culprit
there are now two possibilities
either you calculate the tee by
hand and compare the calculated value
with the so-called critical value
we will look at this way in a moment
or the second way is you
simply use a statistical software  like data
tab and lets you auto everything  at the end of this video i will show you how to
calculate and interpret it automatically
online how easy it is to do
this online so let's start
with the calculation by hand we want to
calculate the tee value but how do
we get the value to calculate the offender
we first need the
number of cases  we have four
dependent pairs so we have four
cases the number of degrees of freedom
results from the number of cases
minus 1 so in our case three
we calculate the mean value of the data
simply by adding up all the values
and dividing by the number of
cases we get  a
mean of minus 0 75 kilograms
now we need the
standard deviation for this data there
is a standard
deviation of 5.84 from the standard deviation and the
number of cases we can now calculate the
standard error of the mean
which is 2.84 which is the
standard  error of the mean the
standard error of the mean indicates
how strong the mean is  rt would fluctuate
if we had taken a lot of
random samples that means the larger this
value is, the more likely it is that there will be a large increase
or decrease in weight purely by
chance there is simply a large
fluctuation in the mean value and
now we can finally
calculate the way the value results  by the
mean minus zero divided by the
standard error of the mean why 0
our 0 says about thesis there is no
difference so we want to test if
the mean is significantly different from
0 therefore the value is
where we divide the mean by the
standard error of the mean  divide
what equals minus 0.26 we would have
done it first now we have to
check whether this calculated value is smaller
or larger than the so-called critical
value we can read the critical value
in a table but how does it work
we have a significant level
of 5  percent fixed when we test an
undirected hypothesis  does
this mean that we divide the five percent on the
left and on the right side of the
distribution, so we have
25 percent on the left and we have 25 percent on the right
in the table of critical
values, we therefore have to look at 97,
which results from
defeating salvation  not how can it
subtract level from 1 so we end up in
this column the degrees of freedom
result from the number of cases minus 1
that is 3 in our case so we are
a table in this row the
critical value is 3.1
now we have the critical value and
our calculated value we calculated a
value of minus 2.6 so
the critical value is greater than the amount
and the t value we calculated
if the amount of the calculated t birds is
less than the critical value
the new hypothesis is retained if you
need this table you can find the table
on the data tab you can find the link
in the video description ok so that
e.g  back to the hypotheses our 0
hypothesis is the diet program has
no effect and the alternative
hypothesis says the diet program has
an effect on body weight the
amount of our calculated value is
less than the critical value so
we keep the null hypothesis and
we assume that  that the
diet program has no effect on
body weight so there are only
two open issues once what are
the requirements and how are they calculated to the
perpetrator is very easy online with data
tab we start with the requirements
the first requirement is of course there
are two dependent groups or
random samples before what is the name of the
perpetrator is for dependent constant promotion
specifies the groups must be dependent
so i have to be able to assign a value to a group with
a value in another group
these requirements are met, for example,
if we of one and the same
person weigh before and after  a diet
measure super so fits the sc  Honestly
for us, however, it is not fulfilled
if the weight of
people who have been on a diet is
measured and if the weight of
people who have not been on a diet is measured. The
two groups of people would then have
nothing to do with one another, so
we would not have a dependent sample either
Requirement 2 the variables must be
metric if the perpetrator is for a
dependent sample, the difference
between the two dependents is
formed and then the mean
value is calculated. This only
makes sense if the values ​​are
metric. A metric variable is, for
example, a person's salary  no
metric variable is, for example,
a person's educational attainment the
third requirement is the
difference in planned values ​​is normally distributed
the difference between births required for the paired offender values
must be normally distributed normally
distributed could be, for example, the
difference in the weight of a  r
person at two points in time are not
normally distributed is the difference in the
number of points after throwing two
dice so you have now done the
theory and now I
will show you how you can calculate the culprit for
dependent sample online
here for googles you can simply look it up  data
tab click on the statistics calculator
and copy your data into this table
then select this tab and
simply click on the variables that you
want to evaluate. state app recognizes in
this case that it is very
likely to be a dependent
sample and automatically calculates
the culprit  is dependent sampling you
can still choose whether you want to check an
undirected or a directed
hypothesis then the
datatec will output the hypotheses and if you
scroll down you will get the
results here you can read the ph value
if the ph value is lower than that
if the significance level is set to e.g. 5
percent, then the new hypothesis
rejected but in this case the result
is a value which is greater than
0.05 so in this case the new
hypothesis is retained
you can also
check the prerequisite
and have an interpretation of the words
output a perpetrator is
dependent stands for samples showed that
this  difference was not statistically
significant the result is a value
of 0.08 7 which is above the
specified significance level of
0.05 the test result is therefore not
significant and the new hypothesis is
retained it is
therefore assumed that both
samples come from the same
population  come so i hope
you liked the video the content of
this video can also be read in our book
the link is in the
video description and see you
next time